también llegó a samos hace casi dos años
todavía está esperando que se le conceda
el asilo dos largos años que han
empezado a pasarle factura al joven de
la república democrática del congo
el campamento es bueno en comparación
con el otro campamento
solo esperamos obtener un resultado
positivo que se apruebe nuestra
solicitud de asilo y nos permita empezar
una nueva vida fuera del campo
ya está haciendo planes y se considera
uno de los afortunados tras saber que
otros solicitantes de asilo en
embarcaciones improvisadas siguen
ahogándose en el mar egeo
llegamos a grecia a pesar de las
difíciles y peligrosas condiciones
cada vez que oímos que nuestros hermanos
y hermanas mueren no se entristece mucho
la tristeza también es visible en los
ojos de alice quien llegó a este campo
de solicitantes de asilo es de octubre
su viaje comenzó en sierra leona y la
llevó a través de iran lo que vivió le
ha dejado cicatrices que tardarán años
en curarse
me metieron en una casa grande donde los
hombres venían a violarme
un día decidí huir de la casa
conocí gente de diferentes
nacionalidades decidí seguirlos en el
monte caminar en la noche en las
montañas
estaba muy cansada por las montañas sin
comida
si decía que quería comer me violaban
antes de darme comida
quiero quedarme en grecia porque sé que
grecia es segura para mí for me
seguro pero también aislado del resto
del mundo
este centro ultra moderno está situado
en una zona desierta al noroeste de
samos alambre de púas interminable
puertas de seguridad escáneres de rayos
x los 360 refugiados están divididos por
origen en contenedores codificados por
colores las autoridades griegas dicen
ser conscientes de que estas
restricciones son estrictas
la seguridad es esencial para nuestros
residentes ya que afirman haber
abandonado a sus países por razones de
seguridad
creés ya está una frontera entre europa
y asia y oriente en general por lo que
su papel es proteger las fronteras
europeas
este centro de cerca de 50 millones de
dólares fue financiado en su totalidad
por la unión europea y cuenta con un
sistema de vigilancia único con cámaras
conectadas directamente atenas
este es el drone con sonido y cámara no
proporciona imágenes pero las patrullas
terrestres también pueden acceder a
ellas
y estas son las gafas de realidad
aumentada que reciben nuestras
instrucciones mientras están en el suelo
los sistemas de cámaras reconocen lo que
es sospechosos reconocen las navajas las
armas y ven lo que ocurre entonces hace
sonar la alarma roja si es muy grave o
amarilla si es menos grave a
continuación enviamos las instrucciones
correspondientes
a pocos kilómetros de esta fortaleza de
acero se encuentra el antiguo campamento
de samos en pleno centro de la ciudad de
bhatti fue evacuado apresuradamente el
pasado mes de septiembre
más que él
las ratas aquí eran del tamaño de un
gato los refugiados convivían con
insectos ratas y serpientes
también había toda una serie de
problemas xenofobia conflictos
geopolíticos
el alcohol se abría paso en el campo
mucha tensión y drama
todas las noches vigila la costa turca
al otro lado del puerto de samos para
ayudar a los recién llegados pero desde
que el régimen talibán tomó el poder en
afganistán las autoridades griegas han
aumentado los controles fronterizos por
temor a una nueva oleada de refugiados
los barcos de refugiados llegan
regularmente este mar frente a ti que
parece magnífico es en realidad un
cementerio pronto se abrirán cuatro
campamentos construidos según el mismo
modelo de samos en las islas vecinas